[Music]
so this week the establishment agreed we
found the villain behind all of
society's ills hate division mental
health problems misinformation that
overcooked state you were served last
night it is all facebook's fault and we
can prove it because we got a
whistleblower with a 60-minute special
and leaked documents and damning
evidence and cover-ups and congressional
hearings and it's just like big tobacco
and all we need to do is have government
bureaucrats dictate exactly what
everyone can post on facebook because
that'll really help
there's something so unintelligent and
unseemly about the way the entire media
and political establishment is piling
onto facebook as if all we need to do is
fix facebook whatever that means
and all our problems will magically go
away it's amazing to think we managed to
fight a civil war without facebook to
divide us how on earth were people ever
sad or depressed before that little blue
like button came along it's well known
that teenagers were always completely
full of joy and laughter all the time
before that devilish mark zuckerberg
invented his human misery machine in
2004 and don't get me started on the
insurrection of the capital facebook's
fault obviously it is also dumb
and it's destructive too because this
ludicrous scapegoating of facebook
obscures the real issues
i've been as tough on big tech as anyone
but i've been completely consistent in
my critique which is that our central
focus should be on decentralizing power
in many ways technology does that it
does put power in people's hands the
power to express yourself
challenge authority if you're an artist
or an entrepreneur to find new audiences
and customers that's all good
but when too much power is concentrated
in too few hands that is bad whether
it's the federal government or big
business in general all big tech
competition is healthy it's what makes
societies and economies strong and
innovative that's why i've long argued
we should break up big tech all of it
not least so we avoid the harm to our
democracy when you have establishment
groupthink interfere in an election as
we saw in 2020 with the biden corruption
story
and families today really are being hurt
by big tech but it's not just facebook
it's not even mainly facebook
screen addiction is the problem we need
to address kids so obsessed with their
phones that they're shutting out the
real world
parents are desperate about this
but instead of helping them we're
getting in a stupid frenzy about
facebook
here's the bottom line
kids do not need smartphones that give
them the internet in their pocket any
time any place
and i don't know a single parent who
positively wants their kids to have
these wretched things they just think
it's unavoidable how can they say no and
all the other kids have smartphones
well it's not unavoidable we have rules
to protect children from other harmful
activities like drugs and alcohol and
smoking and underage sex why on earth
aren't we doing the same for smartphones
which are actually causing far more
widespread harm to kids and families
than any of those other things we ban
for kids
smartphones have been a disaster for
children and families and it's long past
time we ban them for children under 16
as i first argued in my book more human
in 2015
of course you're not going to be able to
enforce a ban all the time just like you
still see kids smoking or vaping even
though we have rules against that but by
setting this standard we can set an
expectation of society's standards we
can help schools and parents
start to reclaim their kids childhood we
can fight back against the premature
sexualization and screen addiction and
family dysfunction that smartphones have
caused hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else